hey remember how Trump referred
endlessly to Elizabeth Warren as
Pocahontas because of the belief that
Elizabeth Warren had based on family
history and stories that she was part
Native American
you're you may or may not believe this
failed Republican gubernatorial
candidate Kerry Lake now says she's
probably native American now I I'm not
taking any position on whether Kerry
lake is or isn't Native American I had
people writing to me saying you know
from her look she may be Native American
I am not touching that with a 10 foot
pole I have no idea if Kerry lake is
Native American I have no idea if Kerry
Lake believes she's Native American or
looks native I mean I'm not getting
anywhere near that but the idea that now
she is putting forth I probably am
Native American is hilarious after all
of the Fiasco around Elizabeth Warren
supposedly wanting to use her Native
American little all that stuff Harvard
admissions it was all debunked Okay
let's listen to this here's Carrie Lake
who lost who lost that race okay very
important to remember she lost in that
she got fewer votes than her opponent
um here she is speaking to Eric mataxis
about Choctaw blood or whether she's
black and then she goes actually I do
think I'm Native American nobody's more
all-in than you are and I it just
Thrills me and of course I secretly hope
that you will uh be president Trump's
vice presidential candidate do you have
any like Choctaw blood or or or or uh
African-American in your back anything
like that that would you know I am I'm
just um American I'm a little bit of
everything and we probably do have a
little bit of Native American in our
family because of where my grandparents
are from in Wisconsin I know sure but I
never I'm just an American I'm a mixture
of everything
um and I always consider I'm gonna guess
Chickasaw no I honestly you um what does
that even mean you're such a bright spot
you know in in in in the political
future of the country and what are you
talking about this guy by the way if
you're not familiar with this Eric
mataxis guy imagine how deluded and
disconnected from reality you have to be
to look at the Panorama of uh look at
the landscape of Republican candidates
and and people you know Hangers On
and say that Kerry lake is the bright
spot on in the American right wing
that's crazy then Kerry Lake of course
uh told the story of how a very powerful
person tried to bribe her out of
politics and this is a story we all
doubt seems like one of these they came
to me with tears in their eyes stories
and every time she tells it she tells it
a little bit differently and I don't
know if I told you this I didn't put it
in the book because it kind of happened
after I'd finished writing it I probably
should have added it but couple months
ago I had a call from a very powerful
person in Arizona and I said I have to
come over and talk to you in person this
can't be done on the phone which I was
like okay okay uh shows up at my door to
offer me a prestigious job title right a
procedure a large salary and a position
on a board if I will just promise to not
run in this next election 24. oh sweet
and I said really I said do you are you
serious I walked away from a prestigious
job I walked away from money I'm not
motivated by that
we talked a little longer I finally got
him out of the house that's actually
funny when when mataxis goes do you know
why and it's like he's just he's just
being conversational but it's a great
question why on Earth she lost what's
there's there's no big threat from Kerry
Lake right now I mean sure Arizona is a
very 50 50 state if she runs for Senate
which we'll look at her talking about
she could win but what she just lost why
would you immediately try to bribe her
out of politics it makes no sense and I
I said he said how much would it take
what would it take just just because the
Chinese have Deep Pockets come on for
two years is just don't get on the they
don't want me on the ballot they don't
want Trump on the ballot because they
know we the people will show up and vote
in droves and they know that if they
pull another rigged election
it first of all it's gonna be a lot
harder because now we know every which
way that they're cheating right every
single one of which court said didn't
happen and I think they know they can't
pull another one like that
so that makes me think I need to stay in
politics as dirty as it is I haven't
decided what I'm going to do next there
is a senate seat that's going to be uh
for grabs this uh go around oh boy and
right now we have uh Kirsten Cinema who
votes with Joe Biden 95 of the time
that's not representative what the
people want all right and then so let's
hear from just another interview on this
Senate thing this is a different
interview uh where Kerry Lake was asked
about the whole Senate thing and she
acts like she's a martyr listen it's not
that she wants to continually inject
herself into politics it's that she
might have to the book is available
wherever books are sold unafraid but I I
gotta find like what are you gonna do
this book is great you're gonna be on a
book tour and uh but there's a senate
seat with your name on it some people
think uh there's a big opening
potentially uh you know competitive race
there are you going to do it I'm
considering it I really seriously am
yeah um I need to get through this I'm
looking at it I know that all the
polling is showing that we have a real
advantage here and with a three-way race
I mean Arizona needs somebody who's
going to go to DC and represent the
people right we have a current senator
in that seat who is voting with Biden 95
of the time we have a socialist running
on the Democrat ticket who is all right
so anyway this is the same these are as
you can see in every interview she uses
the same lines you've got someone voting
with Biden 95 of the time so she may
just have to do it she may have no
choice potentially Native American Kerry
Lake might not be ending her political
career just yet this long National
nightmare will not yet be over we're
going to keep an eye on it and you can
be sure that she will claim she won even
if she loses again remember all of our
Clips will be on YouTube
they will be on Tick Tock they will be
on Facebook they will be on Instagram
and most recently one of these clips
from today will be on Snapchat which is
a whole other world altogether don't
even get me started on that